every time you are rude to Gary it makes
me laugh and he's not there you're like
where is what's his ass and you're like
oh we left him in New Hampshire and then
you just gesture to the nearest person
and you're like can you get me a protein
bar that is how much you value his job I
know you just go to a stranger can you
do this garbage I know I just
want to also point out that moments
later in that scene what do you say why
is my coat like this because Gary
usually takes my photos I
one arm out and then I'm walking around
so you don't even know how to take off
your own coat and it actually I feel
like is an echo of one of my favorite
jokes from the entire show a few seasons
later where you hand Gary a banana you
can't open and say this isn't broken no
it doesn't work this doesn't work
she's attended to oh she's a little
entitled Selena